the crypto and blockchain industries are
reflecting back on a great year as 2021
comes to a close 2021 has been a
fantastic year for the industry from
gaining more public backing to bringing
blockchain concepts like deepai and nhd
into the mainstream
with the year 2022 rapidly approaching
there are already a few interesting
initiatives that will likely take center
stage and create headlines in the coming
year
so hey everyone welcome to this new
video on hottest blockchain projects of
but before proceeding please do
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
before we start let's first understand
what blockchain is
blockchain is a distributed digitized
ledger technology that uses a
point-to-point network to allow for
valid and exceptionally secure
transactions
every block in the ledger has a
cryptographic link to the block in the
chain preceding it as well as the
timestamp
it was first introduced in 2008 and put
into practice in 2009.
it is technology that allows anyone to
utilize
bitcoins since then blockchain has grown
in popularity and has become more
beneficial in a variety of fields
so the first one in the list that we are
going to discuss is
photochromic
as we move into the web 3 and metaverse
eras online identity is becoming just as
vital as offline identity and blockchain
is inevitably playing a role
take photochromic or for example which
develops a biometrically controlled form
of self-sovereign
identities on the blockchain by merging
nfts with user identity
photochromic's goal is to make
identification programmable verifiable
universally addressable and digitally
secure
photochromic addresses the current
challenges that individuals around the
world are facing as they seek ownership
of the identity and the capacity to
protect it
photochromic returns control and
ownership of a user's identity to the
person who created it
so next in the list we have femex
while blockchain and cryptocurrency are
global concepts there are a number of
intriguing
regional ventures
in just two years vmix has
amazed over 1.5 million users making it
the most popular crypto trading platform
in the world
the company is also known for its viral
promotions such as the era of zero which
provided zero fee trading for spot
orders in 2019 and bitcoin pizzagate
which was launched in 2020.
premixed popularity will only increase
in 2022 and we can anticipate more
innovative trading and viral promotions
in the future
then we have is aioz network
on the emerging web 3 scene in 2022 we
will see more use of blockchain apps
project like aioz network of web 3.0
media infrastructure will help to
achieve this
artificial intelligence is used to
optimize this network's decentralized
content distribution network which is
powered by peer-to-peer edge notes
decentralized application for videos
audio live and metaverse streaming can
use the blockchain infrastructure
because of these features
following that we have flare finance
the decentralized finance
field is rapidly expanding but there is
still a need for a solution that can
link
all of the ecosystem together
player finance which will be the first
d5 platform on the fair network might
soon evolve into a full-fledged d5
platform
the player finance ecosystem will
connect communities together and return
the power of finance to the people
through f assets and y assets
moving on we have scallop
as the use of bitcoin becomes more
common
most servers like scallop are developing
to make the transition easier
scallop is a 10 product next generation
banking platform that includes banking
accounts wallets and nft marketplace
scallop is a one stop
shop for banking and cryptocurrency
solutions scallop allows for any form of
transaction with full banking accounts
for fiat currency
cryptocurrency wallets and an inbuilt
exchange
scallop also has a native blockchain
that will go live in the coming months
and will be used to underpin its banking
environment
the scallop al
will be available in europe on november
29 2022.
next coming on the list we have space y
let me tell you this project has my
personal interest as well
so these days blockchain technologies
are also being used in the gaming
industry
take for example space y 2025 the first
three atar defense blockchain game
themed on colonizing and protecting mars
with the backstory based on elon musk
mars mission
it is being built by a blogfish team
which was behind
such blockchain and gaming services as
tencent and ea studio as well as
titles titled
roblox death stranding and the sims 3
and is a fan favorite since its launch
not only have numerous influencers
players and community supporters been
thrilled about space by 2020 by
but so have high profile investors
like ash wsb draper dragon formless
capital
huby ventures and magnus capital
space fight 2025 has block fish first 3a
flagship game
might usher in a new era of chain game
creation in 2022 and beyond
next up is
sushi wars
non-fungible tokens and blockchain
gaming are two areas of the blockchain
business that have taken off
sushi verse combine all of these
elements in a blockchain based online
game that pits virtual
sushi aptars against each other in
battle and contest all of the sushis in
the sushi verse
ecosystem are one-of-a-kind nfts with
the potential to appreciate in value as
they compete
it has gained thousands of members since
it starts released a limited edition
collection with renowned digital artist
laya
matik shara and is expected to develop
even more in 2022
and the last but not least we have x10
agency
because of agencies like x10 agency
there is much more order and
professionalism around product launch
as more initiatives are launched in the
more mature blockchain and crypto market
x10 is a marketing and public relations
firm that focuses on
assisting entrepreneurs with the launch
of d5 sto and nft
extend seeks to offer credible unusable
assessments on industry trends
as much of the crypto and blockchain
sector is based on conjecture about the
next big thing
well these were all the hottest projects
of blockchain 2022
i hope you enjoyed this video and
learned something new from it
if you have any questions please feel
free to ask away in the comment section
a team will reach you out as soon as
possible thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here